[Musique]
c'est de plus en plus compliqué de
trouver un logement dans les Yvelines
près de cette yvelinois sur 10 ont du
mal à trouver un appartement ou une
maison dans le département un chiffre
conséquent et la situation n'est pas
prête de s'améliorer selon les acteurs
du secteur pour en parler avec nous
Angèle Dupont bonsoir ça alors vous êtes
la directrice de l'ADIL c'est l'agence
départementale d'informations sur le
logement des Yvelines alors première
question un constat comment est-ce
expliquez-vous cette situation dans le
département cette crise du logement tout
simplement parce que le département est
un ascendant poids et de services assez
conséquent comme comme toutes les villes
de France qui attirent des personnes
venant de tous les départements
alentours et même parfois d'un peu plus
loin sauf que par conséquent faut se
loger c'est déjà une croissance
démographique trop conséquente et puis
oui un mouvement plutôt qu'autre chose
puisqu'une croissance des personnes
originales du territoire mais c'est
vraiment une un flux de personnes venant
des territoires limitrophes pour
travailler que du coup arriver à un
moment ils ont marre de faire les
allers-retours entre leur lieu de
travail et leur domicile et souhaite se
rapprocher du coup en cherchant sur le
territoire est-ce que c'est dû aussi à
la difficulté aujourd'hui de construire
de nouveaux logements
ah c'est sûr que c'est une des raisons
parce qu'on a deux problématiques le
parc privé le parc social et c'est une
des raisons qui bloque au niveau du parc
social c'est qu'on a pu le foncer
nécessaire aujourd'hui pour continuer de
créer autant que nos besoins le
demandent alors au niveau des chiffres
le département enregistre une baisse de
44% dans la construction de logements
neufs par rapport à 2022 comment est-ce
que vous expliquez ce chiffre pourquoi
on ne construit plus de logements neufs
dans le département donc il y a plus de
fonciers disponibles on a quand même
exploité pas mal de choses il est de
plus en plus cher et et ça va pas aller
on s'arrangeant puisqu'on va sur de
l'artification
0 donc en limitant réellement notre
impact sur l'environnement et en
limitant du coup la construction en
construisant différemment peut-être en
élevant plutôt que en septembre alors
justement quels sont les solutions pour
pallier à tous ces problèmes bah déjà
rénové notre part existant pour lui
donner plus de plus de cachets et
répondre à des normes environnementales
autant que sanitaire et puis bah du coup
repenser l'architecture ça c'est le
travail de d'association ou de conseils
comme le CAE qui vont du coup
accompagner sur de la substitution
nouvelle avec du coup l'assurer
l'élévation de plus en plus attractive
aussi bien dans de la copropriété privée
que donc du parc social et vous au sein
de l'ADIL du coup comment est-ce que
vous aidez les personnes
concrètement à retrouver un logement ou
à trouver un logement tout court alors
du coup nous on va plus intervenir sur
le biais du parc social puisque sur le
parc privé alors énoncé le champ des
possibles et le fait que les agences
demandent aujourd'hui trois fois le
montant du loyer en terme de ressources
ce qui bloque on va plutôt œuvrer sur
l'accès au parc social qui est un droit
en fonction de ces ressources puisque
c'est conditionné à des placements
ressources mais du coup il y a selon les
derniers chiffres de la préfecture
publiée sur leur site 48000 demandeurs
de logements sur notre territoire avec
un taux de rotation de logement de 1400
c'est à dire qu'à 1400 les logements qui
se libèrent donc forcément il y a un
problème donc nous on va les accompagner
pour faire des démarches pour rendre
leur demande prioritaire par le biais du
recours DALO donc le droit au logement
causable pour que ça crée des
obligations de relogement au niveau du
département et alors quel est le délai
pour que ces personnes puissent
retrouver un logement ou trouver un
logement alors le délai médian dans les
Yvelines serait de 17 mois et on estime
que c'est anormalement long quand on
attend depuis plus de 3 ans et la
situation elle
plus plus rassurant pour le propriétaire
privé notamment et donc les conseils que
vous prodiguez ce sont aussi bien pour
les locataires que pour ceux qui veulent
devenir propriétaire
il y a de plus en plus d'accession aidés
sur le département des Yvelines
notamment par le biais de l'Office
foncier solidaire qui a été mis en place
par le Département puisqu'on sait que
c'est difficile d'acheter sur notre
territoire et du coup ils font de
l'accession à moindre coût en tout cas
40% moins cher et nous du coup on va
renseigner puisqu'on a un partenariat
avec le département on renseigne les
potentiels acquéreurs sur ce dispositif
on vérifie avec eux qui pourraient
prétendre et puis on essaye autant que
possible de faire de l'information ce
sens et donc elle a dit ils se sont
principalement des juristes qui
travaillent donc vous avez une mission
d'information mais aussi une mission
d'observation est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer un petit peu quelles sont
vos différentes missions au sein de la
ville du coup notre mission principale
c'est de recevoir le public pour
l'informer de manière neutre gratuite et
si possible objective aussi bien le
propriétaire que le locataire et peu
importe le type de problème le droit
immobilier c'est très très vaste donc on
touche aussi bien l'accès au logement
dont on parle mais aussi les problèmes
entre les bailleurs et locataires la
propriété l'accession à la propriété ou
le gros sujet d'actualité la rénovation
énergétique et du coup nous on l'a on
les renseigne sur les droits sur leur
possibilité d'action et les oriente au
mieux pour que du coup ils puissent
derrière obtenir ou au moins tendre vers
ce sur quoi il souhaite aller et cette
mission d'observation elle prend la
forme plus du partenariat puisque nous
par toutes nos statistiques qu'on traite
toute l'année en rencontrant tout ce
public parce qu'on rencontre 10165
personnes sur l'année 2022 on en extrait
des typologies de ménage un type de
questions et du coup on peut alimenter
cette observatoire et alimenter un
partenariat riche avec les acteurs du
territoire qu'on va venir
renseigner par nos statistiques et bien
merci beaucoup Angel Dupont d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions si vous
souhaitez avoir plus d'informations sur
la DEAL vous pouvez vous rendre sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran
[Musique]